the large protest is over but the
tension lingers in the indian capital
farmers who rallied against the
government's new agricultural laws
are gone removed from new delhi's famous
landmark the red fort
instead of demonstrators now there are
additional soldiers
guarding the city
but the protesters are nearby planning
their next move
they're back in the outskirts of the
capitol where many have camped for the
last two months
a day after the violence their demands
still stand
the farmers want the government to
repeal three laws they say
will eliminate subsidies and ruin their
livelihoods
the protest was a success there were a
few incidents violence reported but the
rest was peaceful
the government will have to listen to us
we willingly came to protest
it's the right of every citizen
tens of thousands of farmers broke
through police barricades and marched to
the center of the capital on tuesday
as the country marked republic day
now damaged property scattered
throughout is a reminder of how quickly
things can get out of control
police say more than 300 officers were
injured
we were deployed to the red fort when
people started breaking through
we tried to remove them but they became
aggressive we didn't want to use force
against farmers so he exercised as much
restraint as possible
the farmers say the government of prime
minister narendra modi is highlighting
incidents of violence to undermine their
movement
we don't support the incidents of
violence that happened at redford we
condemn them
it's not our objective and it should not
have happened it embarrassed the
movement and we regret that
with negotiations at a standstill
security is on high alert
farmers say they plan to march to
india's parliament building next week
when the government is scheduled to
present its annual budget
katie lopez al jazeera